why you trains carrying North Dakota
crude blowing up turns out there's more
than one reason reason one there's just
a lot more oil the Bakken Shale
formation in North Dakota is a key part
of the recent domestic oil boom by the
end of 2013 Bakken was producing nearly
1 million barrels of oil a day back in
2010 it only produced a third of them
reason to there aren't any major
pipelines out of North Dakota which
means oil coming from Bakken has to be
either transported by train or by barge
currently there are about 300,000 oil
train cars and service reason three
experts have determined that Bakken oil
throws off more gases than other crews
those gases can ignite easily turning a
derailment and oil spill into a massive
explosion some safety experts are
calling for better rail cars with
features like reinforced hulls breakaway
valve handles and a protective cap but
upgrading rail cars cost as much as
forty five thousand dollars per car and
new pipelines well that would require
large amounts of time money and
political will thanks to oil production
North Dakota enjoys the nation's lowest
unemployment rate but the trade-off for
a booming economy is the potentially
dangerous combination of lots of
combustible oil being carried on lots of
drinks